here's the question that matters right
because we're beginning to get all the
tools together to evolve ourselves and
we'll get involved bacteria and we can
evolve plants and we convolve animals
and we're now reaching the point where
we really have to ask is it really
Ithaca land do we want to evolve human
beings as you're thinking about that let
me talk about that in the context of
prosthetics prosthetics past present
future so this is the iron hand belonged
to one of the German counts love to
fight lost his arm in one of these
battles no problem you just made a suit
of armor put it on
perfect prosthetic that's where the
concept of ruling with an iron fist
comes from and of course these
prosthetics have been getting more and
more useful more and more modern you can
hold soft-boiled eggs you can have all
types of controls and as you're thinking
about that they're wonderful people like
Hugh hare who've been building
absolutely extraordinary prosthetics so
the wonderful Aimee Mullins will go out
and say how tall do I want a beach
knight or he will say what type of Cliff
do I want to climb or does somebody want
to run a marathon or somebody want to
ballroom dance and as you adapt these
things the interesting thing about
prosthetics is they've been coming
inside the body so these external
prosthetics have now become artificial
knees they've become artificial hips and
then they've evolved further to become
not just nice to have but essential to
have so when you're talking about a
heart pacemaker as a prosthetic you're
talking about something that isn't just
I missing my leg it's if I don't have
this I can die and at that point a
prosthetic becomes a symbiotic
relationship with the human body and for
the smartest people that I've ever met
ed Boyden Hugh hare Joe Jacobson Bob
Lander
are working on the center for extreme
bionics and the interesting thing what
you're seeing here is these prosthetics
now get integrated into the bone they
get integrated into the skin they get
integrated into the muscle and one of
the other sides of Ed is he's been
thinking about how to connect the brain
using light or other mechanisms directly
to things like these prosthetics and if
you can do that that you can begin
changing fundamental aspects of humanity
so how quickly you react something
depends on the diameter of a nerve and
of course if you have nerves that are
external or prosthetic say with light or
liquid metal then you can increase that
diameter and you could even increase it
theoretically to the point where as long
as you could see the muzzle flash you
could step out of the way of a bullet
those are the order of magnitude of
changes you're talking about this is a
fourth sort of level of prosthetics
these are Phonak hearing aids the reason
why these are so interesting is because
they cross your threshold from where
prosthetics or something for somebody
who is disabled and they become
something that somebody who is
quote-unquote normal might want to
actually have because what this
prosthetic does which is really
interesting is not only does it help you
hear you can focus your hearing so it
can hear the conversation going on over
there you can have super hearing you can
have hearing in 360 degrees you can have
weight noise you can record and oh by
the way they also put a phone into this
so this functions as your hearing aid
muscles your phone and at that point
somebody might actually want to have a
prosthetic voluntarily all these
thousands of loosely connected little
pieces are coming together and it's
about time we ask the question how do we
want to evolve human beings or the next
century or two and for that we turn to a
great philosopher who was a very smart
man
despite being a Yankee fan
and Yogi Berra used to say of course
that it's very tough to make predictions
especially about the future so instead
of making a prediction about the future
to begin with let's take what's
happening in the present with people
like Tony Atala
who is redesigning 30 some-odd organs
and maybe the ultimate prosthetic isn't
having something external titanium may
be the ultimate prosthetic is taking on
gene code remake your own body parts
because that's a whole lot more
effective than any kind of a prosthetic
but while you're at it then you can take
the work of craig Venter and ham Smith
and one of the things that we've been
doing is trying to figure out how to
reprogram cells and if you can reprogram
a cell then you can change the cells in
those organs so if you can change the
cells in those organs maybe you make
those organs more radiation resistant
maybe you make them absorb more oxygen
maybe make them more efficient to filter
out stuff that you don't want in your
body and over the last few weeks George
church has been in the news a lot
because he's been talking about taking
one of these program of the cells and
inserting an entire human genome into
that cell once you can insert an entire
human genome into a cell then you begin
to ask the question would you want to
enhance any of that genome do you want
to enhance a human body how would you
want to enhance a human body where is it
ethical to enhance the human body and
where is it not ethical to enhance a
human body and all of a sudden what
we're doing is we've got this
multi-dimensional chessboard where we
can change human genetics by using
viruses to attack things like AIDS or we
can change the gene code through gene
therapy to do away with some other edit
area diseases or we can change the
environment and change the expression of
those genes in the epigenome and pass
that on to the next generations and all
of a sudden it's not just one little bit
it's all these stack little bits that
allow you to take little portions of it
until all the portions coming together
lead you to something that's very
different and a lot of people are very
scared by this stuff and it does sound
scary
there are risks to the stuff so why in
the world would you ever want to do this
stuff why would we really want to alter
the human body in a fundamental way the
answer lies in part with Lord Reese
astronomer royal of Great Britain and
one of his favorite sayings as the
universe is 100% malevolent so what does
that mean it means if you take any one
of your bodies at random drop it
anywhere in the universe drop it in
space you die drop it on the Sun you die
drop it on the surface of mercury you
die drop and your supernovae you die but
fortunately it's only about 80%
effective so as a great physicist once
said there's these little upstream
eddies of biology that create order in
this rapid torrent of entropy so as the
universe dissipates energy there's these
upstream and Eddie's that create
biological order now the problem with
eddies is they tend to disappear they
shift they move in rivers and because of
that when an eddy shifts when the earth
becomes a snowball when the earth
becomes very hot when the earth gets hit
by an asteroid when you have super
volcanoes when you've got solar flares
when you have potentially
extinction-level events like the next
election then all of a sudden you can
have periodic extinctions and by the way
that's happened five times on earth and
therefore it is very likely that the
human species on earth is going to go
extinct someday not next week not next
month maybe in November but maybe 10,000
years after that as you're thinking the
consequence of that if you believe that
extinctions are common and natural and
normal and occur periodically it becomes
a moral imperative to diversify our
species it becomes a moral imperative
because it's going to be really hard to
live on Mars if we don't fundamentally
modify the human body right you go from
one cell mum and dad coming together to
make one cell
in a cascade to trend freely in cells we
don't know if you change the gravity
substantially if the same thing will
happen to create your body we do know
that if you expose our bodies as they
currently are to a lot of radiation we
will die so as you're thinking of that
you have to really redesign things just
to get to Mars forget about the moons of
Neptune or Jupiter and to borrow from
color Kardashev let's think about life
in a series of scales so life one
civilization is a civilization begins to
alter his or her looks and we've been
doing after thousands of years you know
you've got tummy tucks and you've got
this and you've got that you altered you
know here looks and I'm told that not
all of those alterations take place for
medical reasons
seems odd a life to civilization is a
different civilization a life to
civilization alters fundamental aspects
of the body so you put human growth
hormone and the person grows taller or
you put X n on the person gets fatter or
loses metabolism or does a whole series
of things but you're altering the
functions in a fundamental way to become
an intra solar civilization we're going
to have to create a life three
civilization and that looks very
different from what we've got here
maybe you splice them Deinococcus
radiodurans so that the cells can Reese
Pleiss after a lot of exposure to
radiation
maybe you breathe by having oxygen flow
through your blood instead of through
your lungs you're talking about really
radical redesigns and one of the
interesting things that's happened in
the last decade is we've discovered a
whole lot of planets over and some of
them may be earth-like the problem is if
we ever want to get to these planets the
fastest human objects giono and Voyager
and the rest of the stuff take tens of
thousands of years to get from here to
the nearest solar system so if you want
to start exploring beaches somewhere
else or you want to see Tucson sunsets
then you're talking about something that
is very different
you have to change the time scale and
the body of humans in ways which may be
absolutely unrecognized and that's a
life for civilization now we can't even
begin to imagine what that might look
like but we're beginning to get glimpses
of instruments that might take us even
that far and let me give you two
examples so this is the wonderful Floyd
roms burg and one of the things that
Floyd's been doing is he's been playing
with the basic chemistry of life so all
life on this planet is made in a TCG's
the four letters of DNA all bacteria or
plants or animals or humans or cows
everything else and what Floyd did is he
changed out two of those base pairs so
it's a T X Y and that means that you now
have a parallel system to make life to
make babies to reproduce to evolve that
doesn't meet with most things on earth
or in fact maybe nothing on earth maybe
you make plants that are immune to all
vector E emit plants that are named all
viruses but why is that so interesting
it means that we are not a unique
solution it means you can create
alternate chemistry's to us that could
be chemistry's adaptable to a very
different planet that could create life
and heredity the second experiment or
the other implication of this experiment
is that all of you all life is based on
20 amino acids if you don't substitute
to any no acids if you don't say 80 X Y
if you say 80 C G Plus X Y then you go
from 20 building blocks to 172 and all
of a sudden you've got 172 building
blocks of amino acids to build
life-forms in very different shapes
second experiment to think about is a
really weird experiment that's been
taking place in China so this guy has
been transplanting hundreds of mouse
hits right and why is that an
interesting experiment well
the first heart transplants one of the
things they used to do is they used to
bring in the wife or the daughter of the
donor so the donee could tell the
doctors do you recognize this person do
you love this person do you feel
anything for this person we laugh about
that today we laugh because we know the
heart is a muscle but for hundreds of
thousands of years or tens of thousands
of years I gave her my heart she took my
heart she broke my heart we thought this
was emotion and we thought maybe
emotions are transplanted with the heart
nope so how about the brain two possible
outcomes to this experiment if you can
get a mouse that is functional then you
can see is the new brain a blank slate
and boy does that have implications
second option the new Mouse recognizes
Minnie Mouse the new Mouse remembers
what it's afraid of remembers how to
navigate the maze and if that is true
then you can transplant memory and
consciousness and then the really
interesting question is if you can
transplant this is the only input-output
mechanism this down here or could you
transplant that consciousness into
something that would be very different
that would last in space that would last
tens of thousands of years that would be
a completely redesigned body that could
hold consciousness for a long long
period of time and let's come back to
the first question why would you ever
want to do that
well I'll tell you why because this is
the ultimate selfie this is taken from 6
billion miles away and that's earth and
that's all of us and if that little
thing goes all of humanity goes and the
reason why you want to alter the human
body is because you eventually want a
picture that says that's us and that's
us and that's us because that's the way
humanity survives long-term extinction
and that's the reason why it turns out
it's actually unethical not to evolve
the human body even though it can be
scary even though it can be challenging
but it's what's going to allow us to
explore live and get to places we can't
even dream of today but which are a
great great great great grandchildren
might someday thank you very much
ah